hey youtubers it's Charlie so Game of
Thrones did some very big very
unexpected things this week it seems
like they're changing brands story as
well as a lot of things that are
happening in the north just to make the
overarching story of season 4 much more
concise you know without dropping
secondary characters like it did last
year so real quick though before we get
started round 4 of the giveaway starts
right now
all you have to do to participate is be
a subscriber and leave a comment below
I'll be picking one random person to
give a $20 Amazon gift card to tomorrow
in my Q&A video so it's just my way of
saying thank you to all you guys for
being so amazing so because I was so
excited about what happened this week
let's just get started with top 5 WTF
moments and then I'll do my review
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but here we go number 5
Littlefinger explains the purple wedding
we have to give Sansa some credit she
did figure out most of what happened but
Littlefinger just continues to creep the
hell out of us in the best possible way
he wants everything but what the hell
does that mean does he want to sit on
the Iron Throne or does he just want to
have dominion over everyone I think he
just wants to be like a God on earth
just have the entire world serve his
whims like you would think of the
characters in a tabletop game I think he
also just kind of enjoys playing the
game of Thrones but I view him in
opposition to Varys who actually seems
like he has a noble goal in mind you
know not just power itself other big
takeaways from this though are that
they're heading to the Eyrie
Littlefinger is marrying sonses crazy
aunt and she's just gonna have to chill
with them for a while
and probably try to avoid Littlefinger
in the hallways and trips down the moon
door number 4
Daenerys takes marine it's not so much a
siege as it is an infiltration but this
went down really similar to the way that
it happened in the books there was never
really a big battle Daenerys was just
let in by the slaves after they turned
on their masters and now our family has
doubled in size
remember marinas a city is as big as a
stupor and young Kai combined so it's
way way bigger I love gray worm in this
episode it was like they let Daario be a
badass last week so now it was grey
worms turned to have his hero moment I
love how brainwashed he is to you know
he doesn't care about returning to his
home in the Summer Isles he just wants
to kill the Masters Daenerys nailing
them up was also pretty hardcore and she
said she wants justice but when you
you see her eyes it really seems like
it's more a revenge hands down though my
favorite part was that big shot of the
city that opens up to reveal the
Targaryen flag at the top of the pyramid
it's like she just made a giant leap
forward in her quest to kind of reclaim
the honor and glory of House Targaryen
even if that's not explicitly her goal
number three burn gorman is the true
king in the north
I feel like he really won this episode
as an actor did anyone else get a
Shakespeare Hamlet vibe whenever he was
talking to that skull I flipped a little
whenever they revealed it was Lord
Morman like he actually boiled the flesh
off and is now drinking wine out of his
skull this is actually one of the
biggest changes they made to the book
burg Gorman's character is in the book
but they're completely changing what
happens at Craster's but I don't think
that's a bad thing I actually really
enjoy what's going on there it gave them
the opportunity to bring brand back into
the story in the big way and I know a
lot of people were actually saying they
thought that his scenes were the weakest
ones in the episode so far I actually
kind of expected Brant to try and work
in to burn gorman and make him kill
himself and because they're changing
things from the books a lot I'm kind of
wondering if that's where they're going
with this or if Jon Snow is just gonna
rescue them number two Jamie gives Brant
Oathkeeper this is one of the big
moments in the books that I really
really loved and even though they
changed a few small things I totally
didn't mind it it's just the implied
ship you know between Jamie and Brienne
isn't quite as explicit in the books as
it is on the show you just don't get to
see that visual emotion just exploding
off of brianne's face whenever Jamie
gives her the sword and the armor it's
almost like she's so overcome with feels
that all she can think about is honor
and duty I totally wouldn't mind if HBO
just wanted to spin off a show about the
two of them I could watch them all day
that Podrick reveal was so much fun just
a perfect way to cut the really intense
emotional scene between Jamie and
Brienne in the books Podrick also ends
up traveling with her but instead of
Tyrion and Jaime sending him with her
officially he just kind of stopped her
from a distance until she accepted his
presence I really hope that they get
some funny scenes in the next couple of
episodes because I love both those
characters you know even though Podrick
is kind of like a non-speaking role for
the most part and my number one WTF
moment here the court of the White
Walkers all I could think about is that
white Walker rode into the landscape was
of the witch king's castle from Lord of
the
it looked like Superman's Fortress of
Solitude if it were designed by the
witch-king of Angmar I saw a lot of
people complaining on Twitter that this
was actually a winds of winter spoiler
but I don't know if that's true you know
no one has read winds of winter but but
it's kind of implied that we're gonna
get to see a lot more white Walker
centric stuff whatever that book is
released just because it's you know
literally almost the last book the white
Walker that performed the transformation
on the baby looked like it held more
rank than the one that brought the baby
like he had a crown on his head I
couldn't really tell but it seems like
they have their own sense of hierarchy
they have their own types of magic that
they perform like necromancy but so far
we haven't got a really detailed
explanation of their culture yet so this
scene was actually really exciting for
people that have read the books and for
people that are just watching the show
in fact I'll actually go on to say that
I like this scene just as much as I like
Joffrey's death and somehow I have a
feeling the show is gonna do something
to top it before the season is over the
really big take away I think from this
thing though is that now we know where
the White Walkers come from they're not
born and they're not Undead like the
whites are they're not reanimated
corpses they're literally just turned
from regular human babies and then
raised so much more that we could talk
about but let me know what were your
favorite WTF moments from the episode
you know core to the white walkers burn
gorman just being awesome or something
else so right now here's actually a
bunch of big important plot threads that
we need to keep track of but that I
didn't think we're necessarily important
enough is my top 5 Janos Slynt and
Alliser thorne are plotting to get rid
of Jon Snow just by letting himself get
killed at Craster's keep your eyes on
them and then there's a lock
mysteriously appearing at the Nights
Watch it seems like he's been tailing
Jon Snow everywhere he goes just waiting
for the right moment to kill him for
Roose Bolton remember they're trying to
secure their claim on the north the
Kingslayer brothers have started to bond
and I totally love it it seems like the
hatred that they're both getting from
Cersei and Tywin is really bringing them
together and another major change from
the books it seems like we finally found
out why they aged Tommen up and recast
the actor so that they could do these
you know sexy Margaery scenes how funny
was it that the Queen of thorns revealed
she killed Joffrey and humped her
husband so hard that he couldn't walk
the night before they got buried in the
same sentence I used to think of her as
being a female Tywin but she just got
way more
than him I was really bummed that they
recast Tommen just for hump day but they
totally gave us sir pounce who was this
really fun part in the books so it's
like they take something away with one
hand and give us a treat with the other
and that actually reminds me I heard at
least three separate characters making
jokes about losing their right hand it's
like the writers are trolling Jamie one
of my overall favorite lines from the
episode though was when the Queen of
thorns said marrying a Targaryen back
then was all the rage overall the
episode was just flat-out amazing I gave
it a solid a for use of burn gorman and
White Walkers I think they did a really
good job of addressing issues with
brands character from last season by
bringing him back into the story around
the wall and I love that they're making
show Sansa a lot smarter than book Sansa
so on off even though they did make some
you know big big changes from the books
you know namely mega White Walkers scene
I totally love what they did there were
also some really amazing CG landscape
sequences that reminded me when Jon Snow
climbed the wall last season and you
know they showed that big wide shot
south of the wall like Daenerys on top
of the pyramid and then there was also
that cool night shot of the city
whenever they were breaking in and then
there was the just flat-out crazy Lord
of the Rings white Walker mountain shot
I think they're able to spend money on
that kind of stuff just because they
don't put dragons in every episode so if
you ever wondered why they're not around
all the time it's because they want to
do big cg landscapes but let me know
what you thought about the big changes
they made in the episode as well as that
you know major White Walkers scene like
I said my Q&A will post tomorrow be sure
to subscribe to get it
also announce who the giveaway winners
and that leave me suggestions for future
bonus videos too although given what we
just saw I might have to do a white
Walker one pretty soon so right now
click here to get that Q&A video add the
annotation as soon as I post it and
click here to learn all about the
Bloodraven
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow high fives
[Music]